I was taking a look yesterday at Donald Trump's
latest FEC filing for campaign spending. Very
exciting reading. I'll tell you it, it, I
recommend you look at it riveting. Really.
It's like a John Le Carre novel and it's not
just being president that has been really
profitable for Donald Trump and his family.
Merely running for president is funneling
tons of cash into Donald Trump's pocket and
that of his family and his business partners.
Because Donald Trump's campaign rents Donald
Trump's Trump tower and other spaces regularly,
Donald Trump camped. Donald Trump's campaign
buys food from Donald Trump's restaurants
and from his hotels.
If you look at the schedule B in Donald Trump's
recent FEC filings as I did yesterday, you
will find charges including $75,000 for renting
out a space at Trump tower on fifth Avenue,
$6,000 restaurant bills. You can get a lot
of turtle soup and frog legs for $6,000 the
Trump campaign regularly cutting checks to
Trump Plaza, Trump hotels, Trump restaurants,
the Trump hotel collection. It is very profitable
for Donald Trump's family, not even to have
Trump as president, which is very profitable
just for Trump to run for president. It is
extremely lucrative and it is every aspect
of it that is profitable. Foreign leaders
come to the, to the United States, they go
to D C they stay at Trump's DC hotel specifically
to Curry favor with Donald Trump to ingratiate
themselves with Donald Trump. His campaign
makes him money by renting out his venues
for events. His brother, companies in which
his brother holds an ownership stake, have
received a ton of government contracts since
Donald Trump became president.
A lot of people don't even know Trump has
a brother who's alive. A lot of people know
about Trump's brother who tragically died
by suicide. They don't know Trump has a brother
still alive, making tons of money off of government
contracts. And what do you think his followers
would say if you went to them and said, Hey,
ah, your donations that you made to Trump,
they're going back into Trump's pocket when
his campaign pays to rent out his tower, Trump
tower, ballroom and orders food at Trump's
restaurants. I know what they would say. They
would say, that's great. They would say, every
politician does this. They're all corrupt.
I would rather the money go to Trump's businesses
rather than some sissy liberal restaurant
at a hipster hotel or something like that.
So nothing will happen. Things will continue.
Donald Trump will continue to align his pockets
and those of his family by virtue of being
president.
And there won't even be the mere possibility
of holding him accountable. So should we even
do these stories anymore? That's my question
to you. We know there will be no consequences
to Donald Trump for this. The, the emoluments
clause violations that have been committed
by Donald Trump are numerous. Um, we could
talk about, you know, Ivanka previously sitting
in for the secretary of state, we could talk
about Jared Kushner and all of these, uh,
completely immoral connections of unelected
people who supposedly weren't going to be
involved in politics being involved in politics
at the high level. We can say had Democrats
brought impeachment along Amalia cement lines,
it would be a far more open and shut case
than the way that Trump's lawyers have been
able to muddle up and muddy up. Um, the case
related to Ukraine and, uh, abusive power
and obstruction of Congress. We, we've had
those conversations.
We can continue to have them. I can continue
to pull FEC reports of Trump just funneling
money right back into his own pockets, through
his campaign donors. But should I do it in
the sense that there aren't going to be consequences?
I want to hear from you. Let me know whether
you think these stories should continue to
be covered on
the David Pakman show,